the Emmy award-winning documentary
series making a murderer brought
international attention to a homicide
case in Wisconsin Steven Avery and
Brendan Dassey are serving prison
sentences for the 2005 murder of a
photographer Teresa Halbach the 10 part
series paints a picture of what some say
was severe misconduct by investigators
and it also raises questions about the
fairness of the convictions now this is
not the first controversy surrounding a
case involving Steven Avery DNA evidence
exonerated Steven Avery back in 2003 18
years after going to prison for a rape
he did not commit there isn't one iota
of physical evidence in this case the
connect Steven Avery to it but two years
into his freedom
Avery became the focus of the murder
investigation of photographer Teresa
Halbach the evidence that we collected
is leading us to that of a human person
ironically haul box last stop Monday was
it Steven Avery's home haul box car with
Avery's blood in it was discovered in
his family salvage yard her cremated
remains were found steps from his
trailer a breeze defense argued some
investigators who helped wrongfully
convicted for rape planted evidence and
forced Avery's learning-disabled nephew
Brendan Dassey into a false confession
shot her in half it's not a documentary
at all it's a advocacy piece former
District Attorney Ken Kratz told CBS
this morning the series ignores
incriminating evidence that was
presented in the trial it does very
little to help the search for the truth
that's a function that is uniquely given
to jurors and the jurors did that when
they returned their verdicts we the jury
find the defendant Steven a Avery guilty
of first-degree intentional homicide we
spoke to a Brees former defense lawyers
in 2016 there both of you convinced of
his innocence I'm not convinced of his
guilt you're saying there there is some
doubt in your mind sure apps
and if it was okay to can convict people
on maybes I wouldn't be worried about
this but it's not Forbes called the
documentary Netflix most significant
show ever part two picks up with Steven
Avery and Britain and a cease
post-conviction legal fight viewers are
also introduced to Avery's new
high-profile attorney her name is
Catherine
Kathleen rather zelner every crime makes
sense every crime can be unraveled you
can figure it out you have to understand
the victim you have to understand the
nature of the crime and you must
understand in intimate detail the crime
scene and I don't think any of that was
done in this case first on CBS this
morning filmmakers Laura Ricciardi and
Moira demos join us at the table to
discuss good to see you guys so I'm
curious about took part two because they
had both been convicted their appeals
have been overturned why would you even
think there is a part two to this case
Laura well we knew that both Stephen and
Brendan although they're serving life in
prison
Stephen without the possibility of
parole Brendan will be eligible for
parole in 2048 at the age of 59 they
continue to maintain their innocence and
they're committed to fighting to free
themselves and clear their names were
you planning to always do a part two no
it's so definitely something that
evolved how did it evolve what did you
see that you thought okay we need to
keep going Moira so you know when we
leave off at the end of part one you
know Stephen himself is saying he's
going to keep fighting
Brendan's team has actually just taken
his case into the federal court system
and then soon after the launch of Part 1
Stephen got a new advocate Kathleen
Zellner who has an incredible record he
does she's the winningest private
post-conviction attorney in the United
States and so right there it was clear
you know the story really is not over
mm-hmm so as soon as we learned that and
thought about this post conviction phase
of the process which is really kind of a
black hole to most people like what
exactly does that mean
to appeal what are the obstacles what
are the stakes what are your chances so
we saw it as an opportunity
to you know offer viewers something new
in part one as popular as it was didn't
go without criticism in controversy
there had been accusations of it being
one sided right that you didn't get
enough information in time with the
prosecutor do we see more of that I'm
for the prosecution side in part two I
mean frankly we gave the prosecutor
whatever airtime was available to us I
mean we looked for creative ways to
include the point of view of the
prosecutor who declined to sit down with
us I had written to Ken Kratz in 2006 to
invite him to participate never received
a direct response to my letter but you
know we were fortunate in that so many
events were playing out publicly so we
could film those and you know make it
clear what Ken Kratz his perspective was
on the story mentally when you think
about it though do you think about it as
a documentary where you're trying to put
things before people with with no
fingerprints of your own on it or do you
think of it as as a storytelling
exercise in which you're basically
advocating for an argument I think the
answer might be neither you know because
documentary is not journalism it is an
art form and you know this is a
narrative documentary so we had chosen
Steven Avery as our main character and
we had chosen him because of his
incredibly unique status as someone who
had been failed by the system in the in
the mid 80s and now was stepping back
into it you know and in that 20 year
time span you know there have been
advances in DNA
there had been legislative reforms and
there was a lot of talk about you know
because wrong you've been falsely
accused before and falsely imprisoned
yeah 18 years yes yes and so it was sort
of an opportunity to hold a mirror up
and to watch the investigation and the
prosecution play out and the question at
hand was how will he be treated and
accused one of the other criticisms
criticisms guys was about the victim we
don't hear much in part one about Teresa
Halbach you know a woman lost her life
under still mysterious circumstances
some say is she addressed at all in part
- absolutely I mean do we hear from her
family or well both in Part one and Part
two we invited the hall Bucs to
participate and in both instances they
declined and you know I just want to say
we absolutely understand that I mean
they endured an unspeakable tragedy and
you know I would imagine too that even
participating could you know create more
pain for them so we understand that they
declined we respect that and we in light
of that I mean regardless of whether
they participated or not our job was
tell to tell the story in the most
responsible way that we could so we
sought to include a range of voices when
the hall bucks declined to participate
we used archival materials to show you
know the the distressed people were in
when they thought that Teresa was in
jeopardy just when she was missing they
were volunteer searchers who set out to
look for her you had a lot of people
talking after part one and a lot more
people and I'm sure we'll be talking and
watching part 2 thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you and you can catch
all 10 episodes of making a murderer
part 2 on Netflix starting tomorrow
you're watching CBS this morning we'll
be right back